chiracles sont un des femmes bien avec
saddames
comme c'était personnel c'est pourquoi
elle disait toujours après que l'été
dessus par Jacques Chirac et ne
supportait plus l'Irak
tandis que le courant passe bien entre
nous
Majid vous êtes aujourd'hui traducteur
sur la chaîne arabe d'information
continue Al Jazeera au Qatar mais
auparavant et pendant plus de 15 ans
vous avez été l'interprète personnelle
de Saddam Hussein pour le français et
l'anglais voilà quelqu'un qui a côtoyé
Saddam Hussein pendant 15 ans
d'ailleurs j'ai un mail d'un certain
George be des États-Unis qui aimeraient
savoir si vous avez des nouvelles de
Saddam Hussein non pas encore la lui
cherche aussi
il est vivant il est toujours en Irak
oui d'après les nouvelles qu'on entend
oui
quand vous avez entendu la cassette qui
a été divulguée après la chute de Bagdad
est-ce que vous avez reconnu sa voix oui
c'était sa voix ces manières de parler
et même la construction des phrases
arabes c'était à lui bien moi j'ai une
révélation à faire
moustache il s'éteint en blond il met
des lunettes rouges
mais oui oh non
les Américains offert 25 millions de
dollars pour qu'il leur permettrait de
capturer c'est la Mucem mais est-ce
qu'ils font vraiment tout pour le
retrouver parce que finalement tant que
c'est la muce elle est en vie ça leur
donne une raison de rester en Irak d'une
certaine façon non je suis tout à fait
d'accord avec cette analyse et moi en
fait je fais la même analyse que
peut-être ne pas très sérieux à le
trouver ou le capturer où tu es parce
que ça sert ça leur donne un prétexte
très acceptable pour rester dans le pays
et c'est un épouvantail pour faire peur
aux gens qui pouvaient demander le
retrait de trouver américain parce que
si ça ne revient ce sera pire que
maintenant alors mieux te voir des
écoutions que d'avoir
tourné alors vous êtes un interlocuteur
évidemment de premier choix pour nous
puisque vous avez été donc comme je l'ai
dit pendant 15 ans
l'interprète pour le français l'anglais
de Saddam Hussein et vous publiez
aujourd'hui chez Fayard un livre qui
s'appelle les années sa révélation
exclusive avec deux journalistes
français Christian Chesnot et Georges
malbruno alors la première surprise
quand on lit votre livre c'est
qu'effectivement on découvre que vous
êtes Kurdes et que finalement on
s'adapte à qui on a reproché beaucoup de
de choses et notamment d'avoir gazé des
des villages kurdes vous vous avez pu
être sûr de travailler 15 ans avec lui
c'est déjà étonnant ça c'est pas très
étonnant aussi on connaît bien la
situation en Irak vous savez ça donc
c'est un été non pas contre les kurdes
en tant que Kurdes
qui ne travaillait pour lui c'était un
bon kurde il avait pas de problème pas
de problème alors quand vous étiez le le
l'interprète de Saddam Hussein vous
gagnez combien par mois
en dollars
200 dollars 200 dollars ça c'est un bon
salaire oui on ira que c'est un bon
salaire et vous aviez droit aussi à une
Nissan Cédric oui c'était quelqu'un
c'est pas ma propriété c'est-à-dire on
avait droit à une voiture de service de
travail c'est-à-dire c'était pas en
moi-même bon vous étiez quand même assez
assez discret assez prudent dire que par
exemple chaque année le 14 juillet à
Bagdad il y avait une espèce de de fête
à l'ambassade de France vous n'y alliez
jamais jamais non personne n'a pas
interdit d'y aller mais je m'imposer une
sorte de d'autre discipline d'auto-sens
un certain moment on lit dans votre
livre il y a des gens de votre famille
qui vous demandent d'intercéder va
falloir faveur auprès de Saddam Hussein
vous le faites pas vous regrettez cette
attitude de collaborateur vous avez eu
avec Saddam à l'époque je ne rêve pas à
ne pas avoir aidé les autres parce que
le monde le monde entier même les les
parents ne savaient pas la vérité
c'est-à-dire il me voyait à la télé
tout près de cette dame alors elle
pensait que je suis toujours avec lui
tandis qu'en fait je n'étais pas avec
lui quel le temps que l'on voit à la
télécration étrangère est sorti avec la
délégation étrangère est resté seul avec
lui alors c'est Madame Bull magique vous
vous décrivez cette amuseen comme une
espèce de Docteur Jekyll et Mister high
c'est-à-dire vous dites que ils
pouvaient être super gentils courtois
généreux amical et puis par ailleurs il
faisait quand même régné la terreur dans
son pays oui c'est vrai oui c'est
intéressant que je dis dans mon livre
peut-être c'est le travail d'un
psychologue de faire l'analyse de ça il
y avait deux personnalités ou 12 aspects
de l'éducateur en tous les dictateurs
dans les rencontres je le voyais
c'est-à-dire dans un code diplomatique
plutôt avec des étrangers de diplomates
ou des journalistes étaient un homme
très gentil nous traiter de manière très
avec politesse
alors vous parlez des amis de Saddam
c'est vrai que vous étiez aux premières
loges en tous les cas pour les pour les
voir par exemple Jean-Marie Le Pen
venait souvent voir Saddam Hussein et
vous dites entre le courant passe
bien aussi
je veux le mettre pour lui pour le
soldat représenter la France et pour
cela la France était un pays ami elle
respectait beaucoup la France et le
président Chirac et
bien Chirac oui oui le conseil
comme c'était personnel c'est pourquoi
elle disait toujours après que l'été
dessus par Jacques Chirac et ne se
portait plus l'Irak
tandis que le courant passait bien entre
nous vous avez vu aussi arrivé là quand
vous étiez là-bas les journalistes
français vous avez vu Poivre d'Arvor par
exemple non oui oui c'était moi son
interprète qu'il est venu en 90 il se
comportait comment preuve d'abord avec
Saddam Hussein ah elle était très
courageux parce que tout d'abord oui et
lui a épousé deux questions très
sensibles
contact premièrement que est-ce que vous
portez un gilet par balle et
deuxièmement à l'époque il y avait cette
histoire des otages d'Irak avait pris
interdit à tous les étrangers qui
étaient à l'érable de quitter le pays
pour l'étude bouclier humain dans les
sites importants de stratégiques
qu'est-ce qu'il a fait alors
tu es en train de parler de bravure des
Arabes des valeurs arabes de
bonhomme etc Soudan Patrick lui a dit
mais vous parlez des valeurs des ruises
Arabes tandis que vous vous cachez
derrière les femmes et les enfants ça
pour un arabe c'est un dur c'est un
insulte
c'est un bon diplomatique vous comprenez
mal aux questions et la répondu en toute
manière très calme et la absorbé cette
création en disant
sont pas des otages ce sont des autres
chez nous on les respecte mais on a
besoin etc est-ce que vous avez vu
arriver là-bas aussi Christine Ockrent
oui c'était courageux courageuse comme
Patrick Poivre d'Arvor couragueuse oui
dans le sens qu'elle lui a dit que vous
êtes là Hitler vous êtes commis
ouais alors vous racontez aussi dans
votre livre Comment Saddam Hussein est
devenu violemment antisémite
c'est-à-dire qu'au début il lui
respectait plutôt les juifs comme il
respectait les chrétiens en partant du
principe que c'était les gens du Livre
un petit peu comme les musulmans etc et
en 1999 cela müssen bascule complètement
il vit plus les sionistes il dit les
Juifs malfaisant là vous l'avez vu ça
vous racontez dans votre livre Comment
d'un seul coup il bascule pourquoi il
fait ça pour provoquer pour jusqu'à ce
moment-là elle parlait des Unis
sionistes donc non pas des Juifs en
disant en faisant une distinction entre
le mouvement politique si on les aime et
la religion judaïsme mais un jour
presque c'était un surpris pour tout le
monde et la n'a pas de laisser la dit le
juif et je dis bien les Juifs tous les
Juifs parce que les Juifs mentionnés
dans le Coran entre notre
livre sacré ce n'est pas même juste
d'aujourd'hui alors ensuite comment se
l'islamisation du régime irakien Saddam
interdit l'alcool il devient pieux et
alors il y a un moment extraordinaire
c'est qu'un jour il dit qu'il veut
marcher sur des dollars donc il dit vous
allez tapisser le le solde dollar et
puis les soldats vont fouler les dollars
comme ça en marchant et alors il y a
quelqu'un qui lui dit mais enfin vous
savez quand même que sur le dollar il y
a écrit une God we trust c'est à nous
croyons en Dieu nous faisons confiance
en Dieu à Dieu et à ce moment-là il nous
appelle vous il vous dit mais ça veut
dire quoi vous dites écoutez ça veut
dire exactement la même chose que que
Allah et alors il m'a dit ça manque vous
voyez de un gars de Trust
c'est notre Allah il croit en même temps
je lui dis bien sûr
les chrétiens et les musulmans ont le
même Dieu qui est God c'est pareil
il semble que le chef de cabinet était
favorable à
garder cette interprétation qu'elle a
deux dieux mais il m'a dit vous êtes sûr
mais je suis bien sûr allez on m'a
demandé de créer ça de le faire ça on
écrit donc je suis rentré à mon bureau
et j'ai pris une version de Coran
traduite en anglais et j'ai photocopié
la même chose donc l'autre il se dit
merde ça fait chier parce qu'on va pas
marcher quand même sur le mot de Dieu
donc je suis extraordinaire c'est que en
fait ils ont retourné les billets et que
la face où il y a marqué une God wit
la face où il n'y a pas l'invention de
Dieu on a mis la photocopie de des
milliers de photocopies par terre voilà
oui alors vous racontez aussi Saddam
écrivain c'est-à-dire qu'au moment où la
guerre commence il y a 6 mois quoi en
2003 là il y a pas longtemps finalement
lui ce qu'il préoccupe c'est de corriger
les épreuves de son de son dernier roman
c'est absolument insensé le roman
s'appelle sorti de là les démons en fait
les démons c'est les Juifs dans le
bouquin et c'est une espèce de fable
comme ça
c'est une espèce de fable sur l'Irak au
temps des autant d'Abraham donc il
écrivait vraiment des bouquins quoi
c'est vraiment
les personnages qui monologue pendant 5
pages dans ces livres et personne dit
que c'est pas bien il y a dans la presse
irakienne on dit jamais que c'est Saddam
Hussein qui écrit les livres c'est le
génial écrivain oui oui même il avait
refusé de mettre son nom sur ses livres
écrit par l'auteur
donc le génial écrivain donc il y a des
espèces c'est assez confus comme style
il y a beaucoup de détails à notre table
beaucoup de périphrate enfin c'est assez
pénible et lui effectivement tout le
monde sait que c'est lui qui écrit mais
on dit le générique écrivain voilà oui
c'est exact oui oui le refusait
de mettre son nom au début le secrétaire
de presse et quand il a refusé on a le
suggérer de mettre ses initial c'est de
H et la refusa insisté de vendre écrit
par l'auteur alors vous racontez des
choses
surréalistes par exemple sur la loi de
la minceur c'est que tous les ans tout
le monde était dans l'entourage de
Saddam Hussein tout le monde était pesé
dans toutes les ministères
on était dégradés si on faisait trop
lourd on était dégradés et l'année
d'après si on continue à peser trop
lourd on était limogé quand même vous
auriez pu perdre votre job de traducteur
si vous étiez 500 g oui
attention vous mangiez peu avant la
pesée vous faisiez attention oui pour
moi je n'avais pas de problème j'avais
toujours à perdre 2 ou 3 kilos qui était
facile
un régime de mais il y avait des gens
qui avaient 15 ou 17 ou 20h
[Rires]
ils mangez rien pendant deux mois avant
Noël donc tous les ans tout le monde
était pesé
il voulait pas des gens gros il voulait
des gens qui sont capables
pour la santé d'être trop gros et il
faut aller c'est pas bon pour la santé
oui il fallait le dire
vous vous racontez la chute du régime
vous parlez de trahison vous dites que
finalement les Américains sont rentrés
très facilement dans Bagdad parce qu'ils
avaient soudoyé le général Maher
Soufiane lui ont donné 25 millions de
dollars donc effectivement le mec et
d'ailleurs ce général important n'est
pas sur les cartes sur le fameux jeu de
cartes que les Américains ont distribué
cette information je l'ai lu dans un
journal quotidien libanais et c'est pour
moi c'est ça peut être tout à fait
correct parce que elle n'est pas
raisonnable il n'y a pas d'autres
explications il y avait autour de Bagdad
4 lignes de défense de la meilleure
élément de l'armée irakienne des
meilleurs éléments de la garde
républicaine et il n'y avait aucun
bataille livrée contre les Américains
alors comment elle peut pas s'évaporer
dans l'air alors vous racontez comment
sa dame pendant la guerre plutôt que de
se réfugier dans les bunkers qui avait
été préparé pour ça finalement préféré
se balader dans une maison banalisées de
ils se fondre dans la population c'est
qu'en fait quand on a dit qu'il était
dans ce fameux restaurant que les
Américains
je sais pas c'était vraiment mais il y
avait juste derrière ce restaurant il y
avait une maison tout à fait normale
comme les autres les ans qu'on dit que
c'était à lui voilà donc il y avait
plein de petites maisons comme ça très
banalise il était pas du tout dans les
palais et pas du tout dans les bunkers
et l'histoire des sosies alors est-ce
que c'est vrai qu'il avait tous ces
sosies qui parlaient à sa place je veux
pas dire ce n'est pas vrai mais à
selon ma connaissance de la personnalité
de président elle n'accepte pas que
quand lui ressemble de toute façon qu'il
soit un double saddames
de soi-même de sa propre
sa propre personnalité
pour finir est-ce qu'aujourd'hui contenu
de la situation de l'enlisement
américain dans ce dans ce bourbier qui
ressemble beaucoup au Vietnam est-ce que
vous pensez que la solution de Dominique
de Villepin qui consiste à dire il faut
absolument trouver quelqu'un qui
reprenne le pouvoir là-bas je pensais
que c'est une solution envisageable ou
est-ce qu'on pensait que en fait la
situation va continuer à pourrir comme
au Vietnam non c'est une solution
envisageable mais pas facilement
applicable
trouver un gouvernement qui est accepté
par le peuple organisé des élections
légitime et honnête ça va prendre du
temps
ça va prendre du temps beaucoup de temps
alors ce n'est pas pour demain qu'est-ce
qui va se passer alors les éléphants
vont rester ouais oui parce que si le
parc maintenant ce sera le cas le marché
en Europe donc ils vont rester pendant
des années qui on peut mettre à la tête
de ce pays maintenant
est-ce que non parce qu'ici vous avez
quand même l'héritier du trône de France
est-ce qu'il y a un roi qui pouvait il y
a un héritier à dire quelqu'un oui oui
la personne veut de cet héritier ce
héritier qui réclame la troncte le trône
de l'Irak aujourd'hui n'avait jamais
parlé
auparavant on n'a jamais entendu parler
de lui soudain après juste avant de
cette guerre quelques mois on a parlé de
la faire quelques interviews à la
télévision britannique à Londres en
disant que l'héritiers de la monarchie
c'est pourquoi n'a pas de popularité une
personne donc qui aujourd'hui en Irak à
la légitimité pour prendre le pouvoir
elle vient pas aucune personne perd qui
peut prétendre avoir la légitimité sur
la se faire dans les élections qui
devaient être organisées mais quand je
ne sais pas peut-être marqué douarnables
ton ami ouais est-ce que vous avez des
questions à poser à notre ami qui aurait
été pendant 15 ans en contact de Saddam
Hussein c'est quand même une témoin à
quel moment êtes-vous parti parce que
j'ai pas lu le livre mais c'est assez
là allez ciao je m'en vais parce que là
en ce moment c'est je cherche du boulot
c'est à dire il y a pas longtemps nous
on est un peu cette réfugiés au Qatar
pas réfugiés
j'ai quitté le pays d'une manière très
normale d'une famille est en Irak ou au
kata non ils vont me rejoindre
prochainement parce qu'il fallait avoir
ma carte séjour à 4h pour avoir le droit
très inquiet la situation très
dangereuse là oui je suis vraiment
inquiète merci beaucoup Saman Abdoul
Madjid les années s'adaptent
et pour être sûr de ne rien rater de
tube abonnez-vous et mettez un pouce
bleu